quickly take you through the ground
rules here so these are very quick easy
ground rules you need to follow for the
webinar so uh in case you have any
question for our speaker Allison today
you can put down your questions with the
Q&A box as you can see the chart box is
already blowing up with introduction so
it'll be really hard to find your qu
there and we would love to address all
of your queries uh so you can let us
know in the Q&A box here uh you can
easily navigate it just beside the chat
box uh so just in case you don't know
where it is uh also about the session
the session is being recorded and uh in
case you want to go through the
recording of the session once again in
case you have missed something uh you
can expect a followup email with the
recording link and also the bonus offer
for attending the session so what
exactly is the bonus offer here so bonus
offer is for basically the uh webinar
here uh and the program uh which we'll
be talking more about and to request
appr proof of attendance for this
webinar you basically need to provide
your full name in the post weinar survey
so the post webinar survey uh happens
when we basically end the zoom session
and there'll be a popup of a post
webinar survey by Zoom uh even you have
joined from your mobile laptop or
desktop and you can put down your full
name there apart from other things which
uh basically will help make our webinars
better as well feedback or how was the
webinar for you uh before we move on uh
we'll start with I'll give to getting to
know you a little better so uh before we
start let's start with a quick poll here
so how many years of experience do you
currently have so you can see a quick
pull launched on your screen here uh
which says how many experience do you
currently have and the first option
being currently studying second one 0 to
three years of experience third one 3 to
five years of experience and the last
one more than five years so now when I
talk about experience I'm talking about
work experience here in case in case
you're confused
okay I see introductions coming in on
chat I think the chat is completely
blowing up uh I see deep says that
feeling great and excited for the
webinar so so that's good to know and uh
I see folks have joined from Gana I can
see uh folks have joined from uh UK
yakuba yakubu has joined from UK please
correct correct me if I'm pronouncing
name wrong and Robert has joined from
Randa V vam has joined from Lebanon
David from Ghana Mohammad from Nigeria
valid from
UAE and Sassi from
USA and Kaa from Lagos Muhammad from
Pakistan T from Delhi and there's a lot
of
introductions uh and uh we almost have
100 plus folks who have joined so far so
we're just starting off and we are just
doing a quick uh poll here to get to
know you a little better before we start
so you can see a quick poll on your
screen here how many years of experience
do you currently have so you can choose
the one which is the most suitable for
you in terms of work experience and uh
I'll just give five seconds more for the
poll here uh before we close this
poll so five 4 3 2 1 let me quickly end
the poll and also share the results with
you folks so as we can see that 43% of
the folks who have joined us are
currently studying 32% of the folks who
have joined us have more than five years
of experience so that's that's great
like completely opposite and 15% of the
folks who have joined us have Z to three
years of experience and 10% of the folks
have three to five years of experience
so thank you so much for sharing that
with us I think that definitely gives us
a sense of you know folks who have
joined us comes from different different
part of experience and uh it's always
good to have your folks uh joining from
different different experiences as well
so before we start uh let let us quickly
go through the the agenda of the session
today so as I mentioned earlier that
we'll be getting to know a little bit
more about you and how we you we can
help you out better in your career and
uh we'll be talking about the applied AI
in data science careers in 2024 uh we'll
be talking about what exactly the Brown
University uh so program offers and how
this program gets you future ready and
also taking you through the enrollment
steps of the program and also there will
be a special duration for the Q&A part
uh now a lot of folks joined in uh you
know when we were in introducing the
ground rules here so just to let you
know once again uh that if you have any
question for our speaker Alison here
today uh anything related to a data
science or the program here you can
basically let us know uh here on the Q&A
box and any any questions related to
program in general please feel free to
let us know and we'll be taking those uh
questions uh towards the end of the
session we'll try to take maybe few
questions during the session as well if
we get any any time but yeah and I think
we have already started getting few
questions on the Q&A box I think folks
are pretty prepared and excited Al so I
think as we move on uh to the next uh
slide here I would love to introduce
Alison here who basically will be taking
us to the program preview of brown
University's program here uh Allison
here is associate director uh and of
corporate and educ executive execution
of BR School of Professional studies uh
she has over 10 years of experience in
developing and implementing executive ex
education programs uh also uh she's an
MBA in leadership and organization uh
transformation from uh qurum School of
Business so Alison would like to welcome
you and first of all would like to thank
you for taking the time out for today's
program uh I see folks are pretty
excited for the program we have already
gotten some questions in the q& Box
already before we have started so that's
great I think they have come with a lot
of questions and they want they're
curious about the program here so before
we start uh basically talking about the
programs and careers in EI data science
uh we would love to know a little bit
about you from from you as
well thank you so much for having me
today hello everyone it's so nice to see
all of you as Russia mentioned in in her
amazing introduction I am Allison Weiss
I'm the associate director of corporate
and Executive Education at the Brown
School of Professional studies the
mission of the Brown School professional
studies is to empower all of you with
the skills and the network that you need
to change the way the world works for
good as we all know we tend to spend
over 50% of our lives at work and so the
way that work works or doesn't work
matters a lot in terms of productivity
outcomes but also mental and emotional
health and so the School of Professional
studies we're dedicated to offering a
whole slate of programming on the top
skills that you need for your careers in
a format that is going to fit in with
your busy lives and your busy schedule
and this is one of the programs we are
most excited about we got to partner
with the incredible team at simply learn
to put together this program on AI and
data science and I really can't think of
a single skill that is more in demand
right now and changing so quickly than
Ai and data science so we're really
excited to be able to offer this program
in a flexible format that fits into your
busy lives that is still a really robust
experience where you're going to learn
these skills that are going to help you
with the rest of your
career so can we go to the next slide
please so I'd love to tell you a little
bit about why this program matters so
much what are the upcoming careers in
applied Ai and data science in
2024 next
slide so in 2024 there is a lot of
research that shows that Ai and data
science is going to acquire upto-date
skills I think one of the most Buzzy
skills that we hear about quite a bit is
generative Ai and that is one of the
ones on this list one study that I saw
that has really stood out to me and this
is from March so even this is outdated
at this point but by March 70% of
students had used generative AI tools
like chat GPT but only 30% of professors
had and we're seeing that same imbalance
in the workplace as well where we're
seeing more entrylevel folks who are
getting comfortable with these new tools
and Technologies and a lot of leaders
who are falling behind and we really
need everyone to be up to date on AI and
data science because AI is
revolutionizing the way that the
workplace works and I'm hearing a lot of
people talk about AI as becoming almost
like a coworker that we're going to be
using AI so much in our day-to-day lives
whe whether our work is in the technical
field or not that it's going to be
almost like having another cooworker
that we're working with and in order to
be effective at working with it as a
tool and a cooworker we need to have
updated skills on things like machine
learning deep learning natural language
language processing computer vision data
engineering statistical analysis data
governance and ethics it's a huge list
and it can feel overwhelming at times
but we hope that with this program we're
going to make these types of skills
accessible to you next slide
please and there are huge rewards that
you can potentially reap from learning
these skills in 2024 we are predicting
an explosion in careers that require Ai
and data science skills and this is just
you know a small list of them but it
includes Fields like data scientist
machine learning engineer data analyst
AI research scientists computer vision
engineer business intelligence analyst
so you can see it's not all just in the
technical field though obviously
technical field is quite a bit of it as
well AI ethics consultant is an area we
think will grow quite a bit AI product
manager and the list goes on next slide
please and we predict that there will be
some really big changes in the trends
that we see in the AI and machine
learning space in 2024 in particular we
see AI democratization happening where
because of tools like chat GPT and other
natural language processors and
generative AI tools there'll be more and
more people who are utilizing AI tools
and not just people who have already had
access to it in the technical space so
that will drastically change the way we
interact with these tools in addition we
think there's going to be an increased
look at ethical AI a height and focus on
responsible AI development and
deployment and in particular we also are
predicting that um there's going to be
more regulation that may come as a
result of um our increased use of
AI and in addition we think there's
going to be a huge AI Talent shortage as
I mentioned we are already seeing a big
gap at the school level between people
who are comfortable using AI technology
and people who are not and we're seeing
that Gap in the workplace as well and so
people who are more comfortable and have
better skill set in utilizing Ai and
data science are going to be more in
demand at the workplace and more
effective at their jobs than those who
are
not next slide
please so we have talked about the
skills here we have talked about the
career paths here and we have talked
about what exactly is changing in the EI
and data science space in 2024 so what
exactly is stopping you from Gaining Ai
and data science expertise so uh this is
just a quick poll to understand that you
can see a quick poll on your screen uh
which says that what's stopping you from
uh gaining Ai and data s expertise now
uh you can see three options here this
is a multiple choice poll so you can
select multiple options here because
there can be multiple concerns right uh
so uh we would love to know from this
poll that what is your biggest challenge
here when it comes to basically taking
up a eii and data science career or
basically becoming an a data expert here
so I'll just readout these options for
you which you can see on your screen the
first one being I can't find a program
with a fully comprehensive curriculum
second one I wouldn't get the exposure a
practical exposure I need to become job
ready and the third one my work shall
you allow me enough time for learning so
these are the three options but you can
let us know on the chat or in the Q&A
box uh basically uh you can let us know
here that basically what exactly is your
concern on the Q&A box
here
we'll just give like uh 10 more seconds
for this poll because I see a lot of
folks are still responding uh to this uh
pole
here okay I can see most of the folks
have already responded for the poll here
but I think I'll just give five seconds
more for the poll here because I see the
polls are still moving in and
uh yeah and also uh we as we can see
that uh folks are sharing a lot of
questions in the Q&A box already so
that's
great
also sorry for the dist disturbance on
the chart here uh I think a spammer
basically spammed the chat so please
sorry for that we have removed the
spammer and now I think I'll just
quickly end this poll and also share the
results uh with you folks here for the
poll which we just launched so basically
let's see what is the biggest uh
challenge here basically when it comes
to gaining expertise in AI data science
for you folks uh let's see what you have
voted for so we can see 54% of the vote
is for I wouldn't get the Practical
exposure I need to become job ready and
uh 43% of the votes is for I can't find
a program with a fully comprehensive
curriculum and 35% of the votes are for
my work schedule want in All Me instr
for learning so thank you so much for
sharing that with us that definitely
gives us a better understanding on what
exactly is the biggest challenge of
facing so now as we move on uh let us
introduce you to the brown University's
applied eii in data science program so
uh over to you
thank you so much and I do see a couple
of questions um that I think make sense
to answer now so one person asked if the
recording is going to be provided for
future reference and the answer is yes
we are recording today's session and you
will get access to this recording so
that you're able to um re-review some of
the details later or share it with a
friend as well another question is is it
okay if I worked as a data analyst first
or should I work in programming field or
data science and um the answer is that
working in as a data analyst first is
completely fine and we will go into more
detail in just a moment in a few slides
about the eligibility requirements but
as long as you have some experience in a
related field so that you have some
basic understanding of what um data
science and AI are then this program is
for you it's not meant to be this
program is not meant to be a super
Advanced program that you can only take
after you've had years and years of
experience but it's also not the very
most introductive either so as long as
you have just a basic understanding and
you come in with a little bit of a
perspective then this program is for
you so um now going into oh sorry can
you go back one slide um thank you so we
are really excited to get to present to
you this incredible program it's one
we've been working on for the last year
to bring to you and we're so excited
it's finally out in the world the
applied AI in data science program has a
comprehensive curriculum with an
industry aligned learning path that was
something that was really important to
us our faculty member who I will
introduce in a moment he has deep
industry experience he has worked at
meta he is currently at a startup that
works on AI and he has also worked at
Google so he has worked at some of the
top organizations that focus on data
science and machine learning and Ai and
so he is very focused on on what it
actually looks like in application and
we're not going to spend any time on
Theory or concepts that don't relate to
your day-to-day job and I think that's a
real strength of the program in addition
the program you can take at your own
pace so can fit into your own busy lives
but in addition there are still online
live discussions so there's a good
balance between being able to connect
with the rest of your cohort and your
learning team while still being able to
do it self-paced in the time works well
for you we also have integrated
assignments and quizzes that allow you
to be able to understand and put into
practice what you're learning there's a
lot of research that shows that we as
adult Learners we tend to learn best
when we get to do something with what
we've learned and this program
integrates those opportunities
throughout the curriculum and it was
really important for us that this is
flexible to your lifestyle and schedule
you can take this on your own pace and
so the program takes about three months
to complete but it is also itself paced
so you can take it a little bit quicker
or a little bit slower depending on what
works for you next slide
please at the end of the program you do
have the opportunity to earn a
certificate of completion from Brown
University and this is you can see the
mockup of what that would look like in
addition you also have the opportunity
to earn a digital badge that is offered
through kedley which is an online
credentialing platform also has the
Brown University name on it and it makes
it really easy for you to share it on
platforms like LinkedIn or website or
your email signature wherever you like
to be active online or wherever you like
to share your accomplishments
online next slide
please and we are really excited that we
are partnering with simply learn on this
program because um Brown University for
those of you who are not familiar with
us we were founded in
1764 and one of our top distinguishing
features is our open curriculum so we
are really passionate about how helping
people identify what they're passionate
about and helping them to learn in that
area and so if you are excited about
data science and AI we want to help you
to um you know build on that that love
for that and we are an ivy league
university known for Innovative
education multi-disciplinary research
complex problem solving and community
service and so it was a no-brainer to
bring this curriculum to you in this
format we have an extensive network of
over a 100,000 alumni making impact
across various Industries and you would
become a part of that broader Alumni
network and we have over 10,000 students
enrolled in undergraduate graduate and
professional
programs next slide
please the eligibility and prerequisites
for this program there are three of them
one is a basic understanding of
mathematics and programming Concepts and
there are some additional units that are
available for those of you who are
looking to brush up on on some of those
so if you have um taken some programming
classes but it's been a while there are
some optional um foundational courses
that simply learn also offers to help
you get caught up on those as well
secondly you must be at least 18 years
old with a high school diploma or
equivalent and thirdly you're encouraged
to have prior work experience but it's
not necessarily required is there
anything you'd like to add to that
Russia uh no I think that covers
eligibity here I think we did have a
question on uh you know if there
someone's eligible on this program or
not I think that explains it you need to
be at least be 18 years of age and with
a high school diploma or equivalent so
uh I think thank you so much for taking
us to that Alison and also let's talk
about how this program basically
prepares you so uh so here as we can see
how this program builds your EIN in uh
data science skills step by step so uh
Alison can you take us through these uh
steps to make us understand what exactly
happens here in this program yeah I'm
Happ too is the curriculum is broken
down into these modules and each of
these modules has videos where you learn
directly from our incredible faculty
member and assignments for you to put
what you've learned into practice so
first you get an induction which is an
overall orientation to the program that
one is live and conducted by simply
learns incredible teaching team then you
go into the foundations of data science
you learn how to understand the data and
then you jump right into a long-term pro
project where you are learning how to
actually create a model that will work
for you and your workplace so you'll
learn how to prepare the model train the
model do deep learning there's a new
unit that we're really excited about
this was not part of our original
curriculum but as we were putting this
together it became very clear the
generative AI is a crucial skill and so
we added a unit on generative AI to make
sure that this program is as up todate
as possible and then through throughout
the um the program you'll have the
opportunity to do several different
projects which you'll go into detail
about in just one moment and you'll do a
Capstone project where you're putting
everything that you learned into
practice so everything that we teach the
goal is for you to be able to use it
right away it's not meant to be
theoretical or academic it's meant to be
something that you can go back into your
classroom or sorry not your classroom
into your workplace and use right
away and in addition to all of these um
asynchronous modules where you have the
chance to do it on your own time we also
do have electives where once a month you
can come to a live class that is taught
by our faculty member shrier prad and he
will be able to teach things that are um
a little bit more kind of like the
current events of what's kind of U what
people are thinking about right
now yes as I just mentioned about the
electives part so electives come as a
part of the program uh they are optional
and we don't charge anything extra for
that so that is basically a part of the
program so moving on as Allison has
already mentioned about a world
respected faculty uh in this program
here Shri Kur Prasad uh so I think you
can speak more about him yes i' be happy
too he's incredible I'm really excited
for all of you to get the chance to
learn from him he's an adun professor of
programming and data science at the
Brown University Watson Institute and in
addition he has deep practical
experience he has held artificial
intelligence product and Technology
leadership positions at meta platforms
which is they oversee um Facebook for
example Wayfair and alphabet which is
the parent company to Google and so for
shrier he's very interested in making
everything applied and making sure that
what you learn is something that you can
use right away and he has a lot of
experience teaching within a classroom
as well so a lot of the content is
delivered by him via recordings and then
you also have the chance to learn from
him live once a month through these
optional elective um master classes as
well uh also Alison I think we do have
one similar question uh from Deep here
uh which says that uh do we get recorded
session if we miss the
lectures yes so the majority of the
program is pre-recorded meaning you can
access it any time on your own time the
master classes they are elective so
they're optional and they are live
I believe that they are also recorded do
you know Rashia can you confirm that yes
yes yeah yeah yeah okay so they are also
recording you can access them afterwards
I think um they are best if you're able
to come to them in person because or
sorry not in person they're online but
if you can come to them live because
they're going to be highly interactive
and you get the chance to actually
practice what you learn in real time but
if you're not able to they are
accessible via recording afterwards
totally agree with that uh so basically
uh there's a whole scenario of a peer
and instructor inter interaction which
happens uh during the sessions and also
there will be a pre-recorded videos as
well to learn from as well so I hope
that answers your question Also let's
talk about the tools lities and
platforms they'll be learning in this
program I think we can start with
someone who basically know has no idea
about EI or data science I think it
start with a tool or library or platform
they can start with as well in this
program
yes
absolutely and that is that was the way
we thought about this program when we
were putting this together the idea was
that you could come into this program
having very little experience with
programming or data science and you
could still come into this program and
get a lot out of it or you could be
someone who's had a couple of years of
experience and still get a lot out of it
and so um when we sat down with Dr
Prasad to kind of ask what makes the the
most sense and what are the most in
demand tools these were the ones that he
said are the ones that every person
who's going to have a career in the data
science field really needs and that is
python pandas numpy and chat GPT I think
are amongst the ones that are used the
most out of these and he gives in
addition to um going over the tools at a
high level he does demos where he
actually uses the tool in a recorded
fashion where you can see and follow
along and then you are given assignments
where you get to use the tool yourself
so you get to learn these tools by
getting the definition of what they are
and why they matter seeing him do it
live and actually working through a data
set live and he does it um he does it
for you spontaneously so he brings up
the data set and actually works through
the messiness of real numbers in front
of you in a way that I think is is
really special and really helps you to
see what that would look like in
practice and then you get the chance to
put it into practice through the
projects uh thank you so much Allison
for taking us to the tools libraries and
platforms here in the program uh as we
have covered the tools Li platforms and
also what exactly you get from this
program let's not forget the projects
here right uh for someone who does not
have any experience in EI data science
uh whenever basically they basically
complete a course or EI ml or science
they have always asked for experience
right but usually people don't have
experience like they have just completed
a program of study de right so how does
these projects uh help in showcasing
that you know experience for someone who
basically uh does not come from an EI
data science background but uh this
basically program does help with a lot
of projects which you can add to your
portfolio yes absolutely you will
complete four projects plus a Capstone
project throughout your time in this
class the first project is on a retail
sales analysis the second is on employee
turnover analysis the third is a loan
repayment prediction and the fourth is
identif is to identify credit card
fraudulent
transactions and so the goal of these
four is to show you four very different
uses of the same tools so whether you
are coming from a retail background an
HR background using this for more of
your personal life or coming at this
from a financial services background you
will leave with the understanding of how
to apply this within your industry and
as Rasha mentioned you will leave with
some pre- ready portfolio items that you
can bring into an interview or into a um
performance review to get a promotion to
show like these are the projects I was
able to complete these are the skills
that I have that I could bring to your
organization uh thank you so much for
answering that and also taking us
through these projects here uh let's uh
we have talked about the skills here we
have talked about the career Parts you
can take up in Ai and data science here
and we have talked about how this
program basically uh you know lets you
cover uh your skills and basically lets
you add on these projects which in
shortcase to in your portfolio uh we
have talked about how applied eii in
data science program by Brown University
helps you uh with basically showcasing
your uh work for someone who does not
have any experience in AI data science
to the caption project and also the
industry projects we can you can add
from and also a lot of tools libraries
and platforms you can cover in this
program so are you interested in
enrolling into the applied eii and data
science program by Brown University and
also let's not forget the bonus offer
here as well which you can apply for
attending this webinar here so you can
see a quick pull on your screen here
which says that are you interested in
enrolling to the program and uh to
options here so by selecting yes you'll
be showing your interest to enrollment
into the brown University's program and
also availing the bonus offer which
you'll be getting for attending this
webinar today so uh I think as they were
speaking folks are very quick so uh they
actually have shared a lot of interest
in enrollment already so that's great
but I think we'll give enough time for
other folks as well because we have
gotten like some 200 plus folks here
joining this uh webinar today and also
uh not to forget this webinar is also
live on our YouTube channel as well uh
so folks from YouTube uh if you have any
questions please do let us know on the
chat on the YouTube uh feed uh and we
will go and look at those questions as
well about the program if you have in
general we'll be taking those towards
the end of the
session okay I think uh we are getting a
lot of interest towards enrollment so
that's good that's positive but
meanwhile I think I will let folks uh
basically take their time uh for folks
who are still thinking about it uh
meanwhile I think we'll just browse
through the Q&A part of the session here
let's just quickly go through the
questions here and see because we have
gotten plenty of questions in the Q&A
box and uh we will just be uh browsing
through it before we move ahead and also
I'll be taking through the enrollment
steps of the program here how exactly it
works and what what is the program fee
and upcoming CES of the program as well
so also folks uh we will be having a
poll check on basically when do you plan
to enroll as well so the bonus offer is
actually valid throughout the year so uh
we have many cohorts which come
throughout the year and also keeping in
mind uh we also take limited set of
folks workart as well in order to make
sure you're getting all the attention
that is required while you're taking up
this program so uh as uh you share your
interest towards enrollment here I'll be
taking you through the enrollment steps
uh soon after this
point and this is a really good time to
go and put on your questions about the
program in the Q&A box because we'll be
asking them pretty
soon okay I think uh but I I think we'll
just give 10 seconds more because folks
I can see the poll still moving in uh so
I think I'll just give 10 seconds more
for the poll here uh before we move on
uh and also we have a lot of time as
well so I think uh please do put down
your questions in the g box because we
are really eager to address all of your
queries and any question you have about
the program in general or about uh
career in applied AI data science in
general anything related to that how how
how does this program help you in
transitioning uh to Ai and data science
career or how we can become an expert in
AI data science to this program as
well okay I think I'll just give last 10
seconds for the poll here uh and also as
we see a lot of interest towards
enrollment uh I do see a lot of new
questions coming in the Q&A box as well
so that's great please do utilize this
time please do put down your questions
in the Q&A box any question you have
about the program and I see folks
replying yes also on the chat so that's
great if you would like to enroll please
make sure that you actually and basally
answering this poll as well that is how
you can uh Avail the bonus offer as well
through this
webinar okay awesome I think last five
seconds for the poll here uh folks um um
most of the folks have already shared
the responses for the poll here and uh I
see a lot of interest towards enrollment
so that's great so I think last five
seconds so five 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly
end the poll
and move on to uh the enrollment steps
of the program and also uh those are a
lot of basically yeses we got for
enrollment so that's great so let me
quickly take you through the enroll
steps
here so there are three simple easy
steps once you basically have shared
your interest towards enrollment through
this poll with us uh you you basically
the learning consultant from s will be
getting in touch with you and they will
be taking taking through the steps here
so I'm just quickly taking the steps
what exactly will be happening here in
the enrollment part so the step one here
you need to submit an application to us
at ask USS simple.net and uh once you
have done that your application will be
going on for review based on the
eligibility and prequisites you have
share from BR University and based on
that you'll be getting admissions offer
from Simply learn and simply learn
learning consultant will be basically
reaching out to you for that and uh as
we move on the enrollment and the
program schedule I think a lot of folks
have asked about the upcoming C and also
the fee part so uh just to let you know
for us candidates we have the program
fee as uh
$2,499 and I think someone asked about
if there is an Emi option or a financing
option available in this program yes we
do uh so the financing options are as
low as $220 per month and for Indian
candidates uh the fee for this program
is
135,000 INR rupees including taxes and
in this also the financing options are
available for as low as
4,594 rupees per month ion per month and
if you have any more questions as I
mentioned earlier you can reach out to
us at ask us.net I'll share that email
ID after this slide for you to basically
save it in case you want and uh as we
saw that a lot of folks who have joined
from different different countries I
know we have only shared the basically
pricing for us and Indian candidates but
I'll share the link towards the program
here on chat let me quickly do are for
you to check it out as well for your own
region if you want to check out the
program V here uh and the upcoming cohut
for this program is on 9th Jan 2024
that's next year and we do have cohorts
throughout the year so for that I'll
just quickly launch this quick P to
understand when do you plan to enroll so
how soon do you plan to enroll in the
program for a lot of folks who basically
shared interest towards enrollment uh so
this is for you so when do you plan to
enroll how do you soon do you plan to
enroll you can see four quick options
here so I would highly suggest to please
go and uh give your response for this
poll here because this will give us an
understanding when to reach out to you
so uh you can see four quick options
here immediately within three months
within six months more than six months
from now for folks who basically uh are
planning to join immediately they're
sure about it I would suggest to choose
the first option for folks who still are
planning and I'm not sure when exactly
do they plan to join so I think the last
three options are pretty suitable for
you folks so uh those are pretty
flexible options to uh choose from I
think I'll just give 10 seconds more for
the poll because as of a speaking folks
have already shared the responses most
of them uh and we'll be quickly moving
towards the Q&A part of the session
after this and
uh yeah I think uh last 10 seconds for
the poll here please do share your
responses how soon do you plan to enroll
into the program and uh we'll just
quickly browse through the questions and
see uh what questions we have gotten uh
for for basically in the Q&A box from
your
folks also uh good time to go and put on
your questions with the Q&A box let's
utilize this time for folks who still
have not shared their questions here
about the program uh and any doubt you
have in in terms of the program or
anything in the program if you would
love to know we would love to answer
that uh I think I'm getting few uh
questions about uh the program fee and
upcoming schedule for their region so
what I'll do is I'll just share the link
towards the program here so uh you can
basically check out this link for the
applied eii and data science program by
Brown University I've shared it here on
the chat when you open it you will be
able to see it for your own region and
also as I mentioned earlier that if you
need any more assistance you can always
reach out to us at ask us at simple.net
you will see that email ID on the chat
here as well I've shared that as well so
uh and also thank you for actively
participating and and sending your
questions uh in the Q&A box uh your
curiosity really fuels the heart of our
discussions and we're eager to address
all of your queries so we'll be doing
that uh let me quickly end this poll
last five seconds for the poll so 5 4 3
2 1 let me quickly end the poll thank
you so much for uh sharing that with us
now quickly moving on to the Q&A part of
the session so I think um Alison we can
quickly browse through the questions
here if you see anything relevant uh we
can definitely answer those questions
here yes I saw one really good question
that asked about the difference between
a artificial intelligence and machine
learning what is the difference and
which is better it's a great question um
I'm actually going to put a link in the
chat to a an article that I really like
that is is from Google that is
explaining the difference between
artificial intelligence and machine
learning and so this is going to give
you a much more detailed answer than
what I'm about to give you but I'm happy
to give you a very high Lev answer the
very high Lev answer is that machine
learning is a type of artificial
intelligence so it is a more narrow
definition than artificial intelligence
which is a broader category artificial
intelligence is all about the creation
of tools and technologies that can mimic
human intelligence in a variety of
different ways so chat GPT is the one
that we're talking about the most right
now but there are a whole host of
different applications that are doing
this in different ways and machine
learning is about training it's training
a computer to do very specific tasks and
in a way that actually allows them
allows the computer to then learn the
rules and apply it to
Future um scenario so for example if you
gave it a whole series of letter of the
letter a and b and you tell it to sort
it and you tell it a is one thing and b
is another thing if later it encounters
C Machine learning would be able to
understand that c is something different
and sort it into its own category so
that is a a really highlevel definition
of the differences between the two they
are interrelated though and that's why
it's confusing you're not the only
person who confused um but this this
article I just put in the chat does a
much more thorough job explaining that
but this course does cover both so you
would learn both I don't think one is
better than the other I think it just
depends on the job that you want and the
job that you're planning to do different
jobs will require different tools I
think that um artificial intelligence is
probably what is more uh currently being
talked about more but I don't think that
makes machine learning less important I
think it's still crucial so I hope
that's helpful at a a really high level
uh thank you so much Alison for
answering that in uh so much detail and
also sharing a link towards uh basically
for to looking through for that
particular question I hope that answers
your query please do let us know in the
chat or in the Q&A box if you have any
followup question also Alison a lot of
folks are also watching on our YouTube
channel as well we are live there so uh
we have an interesting question from
harshan jadav here who has left a
question for us that uh I is the job
market in ml and DS data Sciences open
for freshes is something uh he would
want to
know sorry can you repeat that so is the
job job market the job scenario uh
basically open for freshers in data
science Ai and ml like a fresher can
join in in in basically career as a
career option of data science Ai and ml
I think yes so someone who's new to the
job market yeah yeah yeah EXA yes
absolutely this is one of the fastest
growing job fields that we're seeing
right now and so we are seeing jobs
opening really at all levels but I think
entry level in particular is an area
that we're seeing a huge job boom in
because now that there are these new
tools like chat GPT and also the
established tools like Panda and numpy
and some of the other ones that we
looked at together earlier I think that
we are seeing that um organizations are
realizing that they need to shift their
Workforce attention towards using and
optimizing these tools and so we're
seeing Fields like product developers
and program managers and coders and even
some within re the retail space so I'm
seeing some organizations that deal in
customer service utilizing Ai and
machine learning to be able to predict
what challenges might come to them
through their helpl lines and using AI
to actually be the first line of
assistance so we're really seeing it and
Healthcare actually Healthcare is
another area where I'm seeing this quite
a bit so we're seeing AI become a really
crucial job skill across the board and I
think that means across Industries and
also across job experience level so if
you are relatively new to the workforce
I think this is one of the best skills
you can get because it will qualify you
for so many many different roles in so
many different
Industries uh thank you so much Alison
for answering that uh hashan please do
let us know if that answers your
question from YouTube live and also
folks who are watching us on YouTube uh
we actually are checking your questions
as well so please do let us know on the
chat live chat here if you have any
questions about the brown University's
programs uh we would love to answer
that
okay uh as I see that we have actually
answered most of the questions here from
the Q&A box and uh we basically uh are
towards the end of the session here uh
we have taken a l a lot of questions
during the session as well I think we
have shared the link for the program for
someone who basically asked about uh
basically the programs and rollment fee
options available for in Nigeria as well
so I've done basically uh sharing the
program link here on the chat what I'll
do is I'll just share it once again on
the chat here for all of you uh in case
you want to check out the program for
your own region uh and uh I'll just
uh okay I think uh we are still getting
few more questions but I think what we
are towards the end of the program so
I'm just sharing the link for the
program here on the chat here so uh in
case you have any questions you can
always let us know at ask us as d.net uh
we will uh we'll be answering your
queries there as well so in case you
your quer is not answered here or you're
still basically thinking about what to
ask or how to ask it so you can let us
know in the ask us at simple.net you can
mail us there and uh before we end the
session uh we would love to know if you
need assistance in enrolling into the
program so you can see a quick poll
launched here which says that do you
need assistance uh to enroll uh so if
you need help in enrolling into the
program uh you can basically vote for
yes if you don't you can vote for no uh
two two quick options here I'll just
give 15 seconds for the folks here this
is for the folks a lot of you folks who
have shared interest towards enrollment
and also have let us know when do you
plan to
enroll and uh also uh you can see the
email ID on the chat here I'll just
share it once again for you in case you
have any more questions basically we can
uh take up here on the mail as well feel
free to let this know
on this particular mail ID and feel free
to mail us there as well and also I
think a few of the folks asked about the
recording of the session because of the
network issue they faced or they were
not able to join immediately or they
have to leave in between I think someone
faced an issue like that so please don't
worry uh we do me the recording link of
the session to view post webinar so in
case you want to go through the
recording of the session once again or
you have missed uh anything in this
particular session uh you would want to
go through it once again you can
basically check out that particular
email from Simply learn and you
basically will have access to the
recording of this particular webinar by
Brown University so I think I'll just
give five seconds more for the poll here
because I see most of the folks have
already shared responses here so five 4
3 2 1 let me quickly end the poll thank
you so much for sharing that with us uh
we are towards the end of the program
here and uh we basically would like to
thank Allison for taking the timeout for
this program review of BR University's
applied EI program and answering a lot
of these questions here we have gotten
here also from the folks here so uh
Alison would you like to see something
from the folks here before we end the
session yeah thank you all so much for
joining us today I'm really appreciative
I know that you all have really busy
lies and that you prioritized coming to
this and that's something that I'm very
thankful for this is a program that we
do really believe in we worked on this
curriculum for over a year to make sure
it was the very best curriculum that we
could deliver to you and so we're really
proud of the results I think that they
cover skills that are very in demand and
very current I was really glad we were
able to add the unit on generative AI
which I think is so important right now
um and so I do believe that this program
stands to prepare you for a wide variety
of career opportunities and fit into
your busy lives so I hope that this
program fits your needs I hope we get to
meet you in the virtual classroom and
thank you all for taking some time to
learn more about it
today uh don't that and thank you once
again Alison for joining us uh for
today's webinar uh please do let us know
folks how did you like the session uh
you can let us know here on the chat or
we will have a post webinar survey I
think someone has asked about the survey
as well so uh once we end the session uh
you will get a popup of Zoom uh which
basically will be a post webinar surve
uh you can let us know there did you
like the session uh and if you have any
feedback for us to make our webinars
better as well so for you so I I I see
few comments coming in on the chat here
DC's wonderful session Alison and uh
please do let us know in the chat how do
you like the session and we'll be ending
the session now so thank you so much for
being an amazing audience and the amount
of registrations I saw for the
enrollment I think we'll be seeing a lot
of you in the upcoming calls uh so uh
thank you so much once again and we
actually do these webinars every week uh
you can check out uh the upcoming
webinars by simply learn here on this
particular link which I'm sharing here
where you can uh enroll for more such
webinars here uh in case you want to
basically go through more uh such
webinars you can check out this link
here and also you can up stay up to date
of upcoming more webinars by new city
there as well so thank you once again uh
everyone and we'll be ending the session
now